let's talk about self-love huh
we've heard it a million times
everyone's talking about it these days i
mean look
in fact every time i turn on the tv it's
like the only two words i ever hear
see what i mean they advocate self love
positivity and self love self love self
love
self love it's all about self care and
self love
and encouraging self love or self love
self love that's true but it would turn
into possibly self-hatred
okay i battle with the idea of self-love
because i'm that person who like thinks
i'm happy when everyone else is taken
care of it's just who i am it's what i
do
but i think they say that's not super
self-love-oriented
i don't know i want to get behind it i
really do
but does anyone even really know what
self-love means
i don't i had to do something to ex
you know figure it out a self-love
social experiment to see
who else feels the same way i do and i
like to get solution oriented
so take a look at what some people had
to say and then we're gonna get
into it
what is self-love
but i have no idea whose definition of
self-love are we living by what does
that
term even mean self-love
it's all i ever hear my girlfriend
talking about what does it even mean
we're just using those words as an
excuse to do whatever the hell we want
at this very moment
is it getting your nails done or like
going to the spa
that doesn't sound like self-love to me
when i think of self-love i think of
meditation
relaxation clearing my mind after a
crazy busy day at work
then i remember i have kids i don't know
what self-love is
um but i do know what chocolate cake is
[Music]
to me self-love and chocolate cake is
the same thing
what does that mean i do not like the
term
self-love i think it's very misused
nowadays
it's also very personal so we cannot
generalize it
i don't know it's just too preachy for
me it's like
the same thing doesn't work for
everybody and the same thing doesn't
even work for you
all the time it's so obnoxious it is so
infuriating it makes me a little pissed
off
especially since there's no clear
definition
does anybody know what self-love
actually means i don't know
i don't know and i can't wait to hear
what you have to say about it all right
it turns out there is a lot of confusion
so
let's rebrand self-love and by the end
of this segment i
know that we are actually going to have
a new term for it
and a new movement all of us together
okay
here to help is psychiatrist dr puja
laxman
new hello puja hi drew
oh i'm so glad you're here and we have
new york times best-selling
author of the subtle art of not giving a
you-know-what
mark manson like 13 million copies of
books you sold
yeah thank you for being here thanks for
having me
and actress and comedian yamaneeka
saunder
and thank you for being here yamaneika
let's bring some funny
all right dr laxman take us back when
did this self-love movement start
yeah absolutely so self-love as a
concept has been around for years but
we definitely see it get more play in
times of
social chaos so especially the past
couple years
you know when the world around us feels
so out of control
we see self-love crop up as this kind of
magical solution
that fixes all of our problems and
social media definitely has
made it worse in particular instagram
because instagram is just such a
visual platform such a performative
platform so it's like people are doing
self-love
just so that they can be seen doing
self-love like checking a box
mark absolutely you have a big problem
with self-love and the whole movement
please tell me why well look i i think
it's good in theory but like most
good psychological concepts as soon as
it's brought
into the realm of social media it just
becomes a narcissistic jerk fest
i think a lot of people begin to confuse
self-love with self-indulgence
um because the idea that using
self-love to get social validation to
get likes and clicks
this is not this is actually the
opposite of love
this is just it's pure ego yeah i
i agree with that in fact yamaneika i
want to switch my questions with you
which is like
does it drive you crazy or how do you
feel
um like or just like when you see this
whole self-love
movement on social media i mean for me
first of all
the idea of self-love is completely
different because it requires me to wear
a trench coat go into a store go down in
a basement and buy some things that need
batteries
so i was all for the self-love but
in terms of like loving yourself and
being happy that's fine sometimes it
can't be realistic
for people and it says higher
expectations but
listen take care of yourself however you
have to i i love that you still go to a
store
i do by the way i don't want them to
have my address yeah i know i know i i
feel you there it just feels weird um
okay dr
laxman you call uh self-love empty
calories for women
how can they do better absolutely
so what we really need to do as women i
think
as look at the way that we're talking to
ourselves and
fix our self-talk so for me real
self-love is all about my
relationship with myself and how i talk
to myself so
we need to dial back the guilt and the
shame
and the self-doubt that's constantly
running through our minds
in a as a playlist really and instead we
need to set boundaries with it so in the
same way that you can set boundaries
with
activities or with people that are
unhealthy
you can do the same thing with
self-critical self-talk so
i think we need to say no to the
performative fluff
of self-love we also need to say no to
guilt
and shame and unreasonable expectations
that we put on ourselves
and in particular instead we need to be
feeding ourselves with things that are
truly nourishing and in order to do that
that means that you really need to know
yourself
you need to know like what matters to me
what are my values what's really
important
and then operate from a place of
authenticity so this means
actually training yourself to use that
language as opposed to the toxic
language of guilt and shame and
perfectionism
for me
i really am like my inner dialogue is
toxic
but i've been finding myself saying
lately i'm really trying to live an
authentic life and it's a saying i heard
in the 90s and never knew where and when
i would embrace it
i mean mark if we ditch the whole
self-love thing
what is the new goal i love what she's
saying about the toxic rhetoric and the
head because that's a big problem for
people
i'm included in that list what is your
advice like what's your solve
to me i think we just we've we've
narrowed our definition of love
so if you think about like raising a kid
right the way you love
a child is you don't just buy them a
bunch of crap that's not
love loving a child is is doing the hard
things
you know helping them understand right
and wrong helping them become a better
person
helping them discipline themselves you
know so in this way i see things like
waking up when your alarm goes off
that's a form of self-love
paying your bills on time that's a form
of a form of self-love
you know stopping after two glasses of
wine that's a form of self-love and
these things are they're not sexy
they're actually quite boring and quite
personal you know it's you know
you can't share them they're not a
spectacle to be seen
and i think that's what makes them
meaningful is because they are
uh simply a relationship between
ourselves
yamaneika i am so inspired i don't even
know what to say
i don't know the things that mark just
said apparently i loathe
myself i haven't paid the bill on time
it's coveted you still paying bills on
time
i mean i'm drinking nonstop you know
listen
i'm going to be good to myself by being
real with myself i think we can't get
confused and self-love
and not being real about what we need to
take care of and then finding a way to
love us and the kids and and the bills
and the wine
well we have rebranded self-love to fit
our new definition
are you ready for it everybody because
we've been waiting months to say that
go fix yourself that's right
it's all about doing the inner
maintenance and we actually submitted
this term to urban dictionary
and here it is this is our official
entry go
fix yourself doing the messy and
sometimes hard work on your emotional
and physical health
as a new strategy for taking care of
yourself
and i would love it i'm doing this
literally today i want us all if you
will join us
because i love a collective social
experiment to post
pictures on social media with the
hashtag
go fix yourself and start a new movement
one that is truly proactive
and not about mani pedis and buying
things as you say
mark and as you say dr lakshmi getting
into
our inner dialogue and doing the work
there
and again i think one of the best ways
to take care of ourselves
is to laugh with each other and find
ourselves in that chemical
state of leaving fight or flight and
just
being happy with our lives and ourselves
for those moments so
these are really actionable doable
things go fix yourself
hashtag go fix yourself thank you
yamaneika
mark and dr laxman mark's latest book by
the way
everything is bleep is out now on
paperback as well and
i just love what you guys had to say i
think it is applicable
i think it is on point it is not bougie
or lofty
or silly it is stuff to ground us with
thank you
this is the kind of go fix yourself i
we all need i need i related to a lot of
it all right thank you
[Music]
you